dude looks great looks great she's
getting really good job if kelly ripa
ever needs a break from her day job she
might just have a future in cutting hair
we might not actually have to go to the
barber shop like ever again like this is
like a game-changer on Tuesday the live
with Kelly and Ryan Starr opened up
about her mad skills
revealing she's the family's designated
hairdresser while in quarantine
amid the corona virus pandemic if cut
every member of our families hair now
during quarantine because I'm still not
brave enough to head into a hair salon
or have anybody come to the house I'm
just too afraid I just feel like there's
too many unknowns still Kelly says that
of her three kiddos her youngest Joaquin
has the most challenging locks what
Keane has my hair everybody else in the
family has Marc's hair it is bone
straight it's shiny it's easy to cut it
just sort of lays the right way Joaquin
and I have the same head of hair which
is to say it is wiry there he is
it's wiry it's thick it's dense it's got
lots of layers
he's got cowlicks so it's like very it's
not the easiest haircut the 49 year old
shared a time-lapse video of herself
giving the 17 year old a trim please
note the look on Joaquin's face he's
like mom I don't know about this I think
I have a future in five hundred dollar
haircuts I cut my hands in three places
did not realize I was bleeding all over
the place
well bleeding aside the results weren't
too shabby thank you very much
the secret to Kelly's OnPoint scissor
skills confidence if I see something I
think I can do it I'm one of those I I
don't like I'm not malignant lead
narcissistic but I have enough
narcissism do you believe that if I see
something on TV I naturally have
mastered it yeah like I believe I can
professionally figure skate every Winter
Olympic
and in the end Joaquin was one
embarassed he's gonna turn right
beet-red yeah totally happy customer I'm
really happy it's I feel much more
aerodynamic now but the only thing is
like I turn on my phone and I have like
the face ID and it doesn't recognize me
because I used to leave Judge Judy and
now it look like Wow
Kellie recently revealed that she her
husband Mark and their three kids were
quarantined in the Bahamas and back in
April Kelly shared that their son
Michael's graduation from NYU had been
cancelled
it was at Yankee Stadium but then his
film school they have a separate
graduation and that was supposed to be
at Radio City their daughter Lola also
attends NYU so Joaquin is the last bird
left in the nest we are truly this close
in 2019 mark and Kelly opened up to et
about what they're looking forward to
most when they have the house all to
themselves and knowing them they're
hilarious answer shouldn't surprise you
I'm truly going to be running through
the house naked I just want everybody to
know that I'm gonna be sitting on every
piece of furniture naked be warned
before you come over that's what I'll be
doing in my spare time